today on the matt walsh show the
lockdowns are having a catastrophic
impact on the economy mental health
education in one country more people
have died by suicide than by covid
situation across much of the rest of the
world is also dire
yet those who push the lockdowns refuse
to grapple with or even acknowledge
these devastating effects so we're going
to talk about that today also
five headlines including joe biden's
injury and another
anonymous racist note story that the
media is reporting as fact
even though anonymous racist notes are
almost always hoaxes
and our daily cancellation i'm afraid
that it is my duty to reign on the
parade of
everyone celebrating a woman's historic
kick during a college football game on
saturday
all of that and more coming up on the
matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
before we get started here i want to
tell you about um our very good sponsors
lifelock which is an important thing to
to think about and hear about lifelike
especially
as we get into the holidays and people
are
you know you're not just online a lot i
mean we're always online anyway
but you're online you know you're you're
using your credit card you're putting
your information out there buying things
the holidays of course can feel like a
never-ending to-do list shopping online
or
browsing can expose your personal info
to a lot of bad guys out there that's
why you need to get lifelock identity
theft protection
because not all websites are on the nice
list and you'll want to know if your
personal information has been
potentially exposed or found on the dark
web
the holiday this holiday season you
could miss certain identity threats by
just monitoring your credit like for
example
if your information is on the dark web
do you know how to find that on the dark
i don't even i don't know where is the
dark web how do you find it i have no
idea
um that's why you need lifelock get
lifelock the leader in identity theft
protection
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number being for sale in the
dark web
and if they detect your information
being used in their network they're
going to send you an alert
if you do become a victim of identity
threat
identity theft they're not just going to
leave you high and dry they're going to
help you restore your identity
easier than you could certainly do on
your own this is all about
number one protecting yourself and
number two making your life easier you
don't want to
leave yourself exposed you get your
identity stolen you don't know where to
go who to talk to
just get life locked no one can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but
lifelock can
help you feel protected this holiday
season the best sale of the year is
happening right now save up to 30
percent
off your first year at lifelock.com
walsh that's
30 off at lifeblock.com walsh
sale ends november 30th so take
advantage now surprisingly enough you
know cnn ran
an important article a few days ago
actually one that focuses on an aspect
of the covid story
that's usually ignored the headline is
this in japan more people
died from suicide last month than from
covid in all of 2020
and women it says have been most
impacted it reads in part quote
in japan government statistics show
suicide claim more lives in october than
kova 19 has over the entire year to date
the monthly number of japanese suicides
rose to 2153 in october
according to japan's national policy
agency as of friday
japan's total coven 19 toll was 2087.
japan is one of the few major economies
to disclose timely suicide data
the most recent national data for the us
for example is from 2018. the japanese
data
could give another give other countries
insights into the impact of pandemic
measures on mental health
and which groups are the most vulnerable
quote we didn't even have a lockdown and
the impact of covet is very minimal
compared to other countries but still we
see this big increase in the number of
suicides
that is machika ueda an associate
professor at wasita university in tokyo
expert on suicides continuing that
suggests other countries might seem a
see a similar or even bigger increase in
the number of suicides in the future
now as the article notes we don't have
up-to-date suicide statistics for our
own country but there are indications
that the situation
will prove to be just as dire here um
if not more so we've seen glimpses at
least such as the report out of los
angeles back in april
that calls to the suicide hotline had
gone up by eight thousand
percent eight thousand percent meanwhile
men's health magazine reported earlier
this month
um uh quote university of glasgow
researchers have found that rates of
suicidal thoughts among young adults
rose sharply during the first
coronavirus lockdown their study
published in the british journal
psychiatry
examined the effect kova 19 had on
different groups at the outset of the
original chronovirus lockdown
by surveying 3077 adults three times
from 31
from march 31st to may 11th they found
that the proportion of respondents
reporting that on at least one day in
the previous week they had wanted to end
their life
increased from eight point two percent
to nine point two percent and then to
nine point eight percent
over the three waves of the study these
rates were highest and young adults age
18 to 29
rising from 12.5 to 14.4
now these are not small increases and
the problem goes
beyond you know suicidal thoughts npr
again a surprise
published a report this weekend on the
mental health crisis among children
specifically
brought on by the pandemic or that's how
they put it you know really it's
brought on by the government and the
media's response
to the pandemic that's my own
editorializing not what npr concluded
the article talks about the increasing
rates of depression
of anxiety among children also
loneliness feelings of isolation
this is to say nothing of the way that
children's educational development has
been stunted
though as i've said many times i think
public school often does
more harm than good children are
certainly not
better off just sitting at home on their
computers all day
but that's what's happened as our whole
society gave up
on educating children because we're
scared that the kids might get us
sick again not not because we're scared
that they get sick because
we're scared they might get us sick and
so we said never mind with education
never mind about that we don't need that
for a whole year the powers that be by
the way
are finally noticing that they have
destroyed
our children and are now pretending that
that wasn't their idea or their doing
here's dr fauci just a couple of days
ago with a surprisingly new take
on school closings listen dr foundry new
york city public schools shut down again
earlier this month i know your default
position is that you'd like to see the
schools open
but how do you make that happen and how
would you advise the incoming biden
administration on getting
a sort of unified response
well you know martha that's a good
question we get asked it all the time
you know we say it not being facetiously
as a soundbite or anything but you know
close the bars and keep the schools open
is what we really say
obviously you don't have one size fits
all but as i said in the past
and as you accurately quoted me the
default position
should be to try as best as possible
within reason to keep the children in
school or to get them
back to school yeah he makes it sound
like
he's always said that you should keep
the bars closed and open the schools he
said that this is what we say
that is not what he's always said that's
not what he said at all in fact until
just now
but even fauci's slow learner that he is
is starting to understand that keeping
children locked in their homes for
months on end
in response to an illness that for them
is no more dangerous than the flu
is madness not just madness it's evil
it's an
evil thing to do to kids only don't
expect fauci to take
any accountability or responsibility or
to admit his mistake
instead he'll pretend he didn't say what
he said in the past and has always said
what he never really said and it's not
just children being decimated
continuing the surprises of news media
outlets actually reporting news there
was a whole flurry over the last few
days of news media outlets actually
reporting news it's pretty incredible
nbc has on their website a short
documentary about how the lockdown
measures
are impacting the elderly uh speaking of
being isolated nobody has it worse than
the elderly in nursing homes
they've been forced to spend you know
what could be and often is their final
months on earth
locked in a building speaking to their
families through windows or not at all
and dying alone with no one there who
loves them
so here's a little bit of that
documentary listen i understand that the
current policies
are in place because they want to do
everything right now to protect our
seniors and our veterans
and loved ones of families in nursing
homes
but our elders are now dying
from failure to thrive they're giving up
they've been alone for seven months
families
need each other
i was devastated when they told us we
couldn't come in
or see him and my father didn't
understand it when we
explained it to him over the phone he
didn't understand what the virus meant
this is my father at 17 when he entered
the service
he lied about his age so that he could
get into the army
and this is my dad in korea
in the middle of the jungle during the
war
so we did zoom calls and then we
graduated
to window visits
and seeing your parent through a window
like an animal in the zoo
hi daddy trying to hear him
trying to see him through the screen
trying to
advocate for him was heartbreaking
you know it's it is heartbreaking it's
tragic it's infuriating
the elderly isolated dying alone
children locked in their homes replacing
education with computers
suicides depression business owners
losing everything
and however bad we think all of this is
it's worse remember that
we won't know the full effect for many
years we can't know i mean what are the
long-term effects of locking kids in
their home
making them think strangers are diseased
zombies
punting their education down the road
like it doesn't matter
in what way will this generation of
children be shaped by this to what
extent what will that
shape be nobody knows no society has
ever done anything like this
and how many suicides will ultimately
happen as a result of the lockdowns
even after we get the 2020 data that's
not going to tell the whole story a
business owner
you know who loses everything overnight
may not take his own life the next
morning
could happen a year later could happen
two years later could happen 10 years
later
many thousands of people have been put
on a path
of despair and ruin this year but the
end of that path whatever it is and
wherever it is
may not come for several years yet so we
know it's bad
but we don't know the full extent of how
bad it is
for that matter what are the
psychological effects of people living
their lives
without ever seeing a stranger's face in
public
how does that influence our mental
health does anyone know
no because again nobody has ever done
this before
and that's why the flippancy of those
who advocate and push the lockdowns
really
enrages me the most they have not
attempted to seriously weigh the pros
and cons
they have not bothered to so much as
wonder about the long-term
or short-term negative effects we're
doing
something no society has ever done
embracing consequences that no society
has ever willingly embraced
and we're supposed to do this without
even discussing it without any sense of
caution or apprehension
except the lockdowns or you're a science
denier that's it
that's meant to be the end of the debate
most of all we're supposed to simply
accept the proposition
that not only will the lockdowns make
people safe and
extend people's lives but that making
people safe and extending their lives
is the most important consideration and
all other considerations
should be subordinated to it we're
supposed to believe
unquestioningly that lockdowns will keep
the most people alive
that there is nothing that could ever be
more urgent
than keeping the most people alive
anything that must be sacrificed
literally anything to this end
is worth it that's what we're supposed
to believe those are the two
propositions that you must believe
you're required to believe yet both are
highly dubious to say the least
it seems there is a considerable
likelihood that when all is said and
done
looking back on this 10 years from now
or 20 years from now will be able to say
with certainty
that many more people died because of
the lockdowns
than would have died without them but
whether that's the case or not the
second proposition
that physical safety is the highest good
is certainly incorrect
not just dubious it's wrong our country
is founded on the proposition
that some things are more important than
safety
any happy and well-adjusted life is
grounded in the same belief
for an elderly person with you know at
best let's say two or three years left
to live
what is better to live those two are to
live those
two or three years and be alone and
miserable the whole time
or to risk living less than two or three
but to be happy
and to be with those you love for a
child what's better to live in isolation
to avoid the minimal risk of a disease
that
rarely has any serious complications for
children or to live a normal child's
life
and to get an education and to be with
friends and to be outside playing and
doing what kids do
while accepting the mild risks involved
the lockdown advocates and our overlords
in government have decided that these
questions are easily answered
and that the answer is to prioritize
safety above all
in all circumstances even if by
prioritizing safety
you ultimately make people less safe and
depressed and suicidal on top of it
they say it's anti-science to question
it but it's not
it is anti-human to do what they are
doing
and it's time for us to stop going along
with it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
i think this year as this year comes
mercifully to a close we've all
learned if we didn't already know that
uh that you never really know what's
going to happen in the future and you
just have to be prepared and protect
yourself
and that's why you need to think about
policy genius this holiday season
you know the holiday season in general
knows how to lighten your wallet for
many families december is one of the
most expensive months of the year
not to mention the busiest and
especially this year i think there are a
lot of families who don't have that
extra capital that they normally would
have so you're looking for savings
wherever you can find it if you need
life insurance but don't want to deal
with the hassle or expense
try policy genius policy genius combines
a cutting edge
insurance marketplace with help from
licensed experts to save you time and
money so right now you could save
50 or more by using policy genius to
compare life insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade or
even much longer than that
those savings really start to add up
over time and here's basically how it
works it's very easy
first you head to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage
you need you can compare quotes from top
insurers to decide
what works for you what works for your
family policy genius will compare
policies starting
at as little as one dollar a day you
might even be eligible to skip
the in-person medical you don't know you
just got to go to policy genius and find
out
once you apply the policy genius will
handle all the paperwork
all the red tape they sort of take it
from there so it's very easy for you
and if you want to know other people's
experience don't take it for me this
kind of service
has earned policy genius a five-star
rating across over 1600 reviews on
trustpilot and google
okay that's where you could really go to
find out people's experience that's
where they're being honest about it
and uh and that's it people love policy
genius i love policy genius
if you have loved ones who depend on
your income don't go into 2021 without
life insurance go to policygenius.com
and get started now
you could save 50 or more by comparing
quotes and you could start the new year
with one less thing to worry about
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right all right um
hope you all had a great thanksgiving
by the way mine um uh my thanksgiving
began
with my daughter vomiting as soon as we
got to my sister-in-law's house
she didn't have a virus or anything she
wasn't sick but she gets bad carcinogens
like i do
and only we didn't realize how bad it
was this time around so as soon as we
got there after a four hour car ride she
was in the bathroom
fortunately she made it to the toilet
unfortunately she forgot to lift the lid
so um that was one of those
conversations as a parent that you have
to have sometimes you don't want to have
but the one where i have to go down to
my sister-in-law and say
hey you know i know we just got to your
house but i need i need paper towels and
bleach
don't ask any questions always an
enjoyable time and i know you're really
hoping to hear details like this about
my daughter vomiting there you go
um other than that it was a good time
other than that and other than
the next day on thanksgiving when one of
the little kids in the house
took my car keys apparently and threw
them in the trash
very helpful and it took i was looking
for them all day found them the next day
in the garbage i was rifling through the
garbage
right before it went to the curb to be
picked up so
that's what you get when you're kids you
spend uh you spend thanksgiving cleaning
up vomit
and rifling through trash bags i know
everybody listening to this if you don't
have kids you're thinking i want kids
now
it is it is worth it in the end i'm told
all right number one um
the daily beast ran some hard-hitting
journalism recently
reporting on a pet psychics
communications with joe biden's dogs
now incidentally the existence of pet
psychics
presents for me maybe the greatest
temptation to be a socialist
this is the only time i've ever felt a
little bit tempted
because i mean maybe people do have too
much money if they're spending it on
sessions with a with a pet psychic
i think maybe the rich people do need to
be stopped i don't know i think
maybe because of this but uh this pet
psychic had a communication breakdown it
seems because
she had a she says this is again the
daily beast is reporting this just you
know
just this just reporting it why not and
um
there seems to have been a breakdown
because she had a mind to mind
ex exchange with biden's pets that
didn't include some vital information
so she says quote the very first thing i
got was that they were both very excited
about moving to the white house
i had a real connection i felt that
excitement of theirs they showed me that
joe biden is very bonded to his dogs and
have a real connection with them
they kept showing me that although he
has rescued one of the dogs
the dogs feel in many ways that they
have rescued him
egomaniacs that's the kind of narcissism
i would expect from a cat
this is why i hate dogs extremely full
of themselves but also desperate and
needy at the same time the worst
combination
but the point is that she never mentions
that the dogs were actually plotting to
destroy
joe biden the whole time not a day or
two after the story was published joe
biden
was in the hospital with a fracture to
his foot
after injuring himself while playing
with his dogs so how did the psychic not
see that coming
why didn't you stop it um now joe
biden's gonna be a walking boot for a
while now
could have been warned about this but we
weren't this is what the daily wire
report says joe biden reportedly hurt
himself over the weekend while playing
with one of his dogs
and was sent to a medical specialist for
evaluation
um uh biden's office said in a statement
quote on september nov
on saturday november 28th
president-elect biden slipped
while playing with his dog major and
twisted his ankle out of an abundance of
caution
he'll be examined this afternoon by an
orthopedist and uh so yeah they're
talking about a fracture i guess is what
he got
okay you know i mean it happens i i
guess i can't judge him i was in a
walking boot myself for
for for months last year because of an
achilles
injury but it does it you know it does
bring to mind i mean we're he
he's not even in the white house he's
not even technically the president-elect
yet despite what the media
says he's certainly not in the white
house yet and he's already
um you know having the kinds of injuries
that very elderly people have
when you get old you become fragile even
more fragile than
than than you know than you were before
and this is what we have to worry about
now with uh with a fragile
old man in the white house who's also
you know losing his mind and in his
physical abilities on top of it
so we'll see how that goes number two
ilhan omar has a practical suggestion
for navigating ourselves out of the
current economic crisis she says
uh quote we must put an end to this
economic crisis with
then she has bullet points direct
monthly payments to every family
number one number two expanded
unemployment benefits
number three rent and mortgage
cancellation number four
student debt cancellation number five
medicare for all including a free cova
19 treatment
and vaccines you know i love this idea
personally i would go a step further
um i say every american should receive
five thousand dollars in gold coins
delivered directly to their door every
day along with a basket of fruit a
bouquet of flowers
a new pair of slippers i mean not
why not if we are completely
disregarding questions of affordability
feasibility possibility then
why acknowledge any limits at all of
course
the real way to end the economic crisis
and there is an economic crisis so she's
right about that part at least i agree
with her there
the real way to end it is to let people
go back to work
and open their businesses at full
capacity
um and allow people to go about their
lives it's an interesting thing you know
you end up with an economic crisis when
you tell everybody they can't work
and when you tell businesses that they
have to turn away customers
hundreds thousands of customers
so that's what you do here's the
solution for the government
as is very often the case stop doing
what you're doing now
which is ruining everything get out of
the way
but of course that's not the solution
that ilhan omar is interested in that's
not the solution that democrats are
interested in because
they see this as an opportunity uh to
exploit they see this as an opportunity
for a massive
transfer of power from individuals
uh to to the government just like we've
seen a massive transfer of wealth from
small businesses and middle class people
to
mega corporations amazon walmart target
are doing very well
facebook you know the big tech companies
so we see this massive transfer
of wealth also there's gonna be a
transfer of power and that's the idea
that's why this is happening that's why
they have the lockdowns that's the whole
idea
and they're fine as long as they get the
power and control over our lives sure
they'll toss you a few bucks
that's just more power and control over
you
number three you probably have seen some
of the headlines about kovid
ravaging the nfl uh with a huge outbreak
infecting many players the baltimore
ravens my my baltimore raves
unfortunately
have been especially hard hit uh they've
got like i don't know 20 players
now out with covid or because they were
in contact with someone who had covet
their thanksgiving game against the
steelers was postponed
mercifully to tomorrow that game looks
like it's
going to happen though the ravens can
hardly field a roster
um they've got half of their starters
out lamar jackson is out meanwhile the
denver broncos
had to play yesterday with without a
quarterback all of their quarterbacks
either had coveted or were in contact
with someone with covet
and so they were they they started a
practice squad receiver
as their quarterback of course they lost
by a lot of points against the saints no
surprise there
but the funny thing is in all of these
stories
you know of a of a league ravaged by
sickness
nobody ever tells us how sick these
players actually are have you noticed
that
i mean isn't that the first question you
ask yourself when you read a story about
this or that star nfl player lamar
jackson
diagnosed with covet your question is
how sick is he i mean is he in the
hospital or is he just at home with the
sniffles or does he not even have the
sniffles is he just is he perfectly fine
they don't tell you that there's a
reason for that
that's a detail they don't include i
have heard specifically
about one i think there was from what
i've read with the media has reported
there's been i believe
one player with serious complications
from covet
um but there have been a lot more than
one who have been diagnosed with it
but that's the interesting thing that's
the only player who the media has gone
into detail
telling us about their symptoms because
they were bad symptoms
all the rest of these players they don't
tell us
and uh you know again the reason for
that is is quite obvious
because in reality most of these players
probably it's
they don't even have a case of the
sniffles they're just at home
you know playing madden or something and
waiting for when the league tells them
they can come back
not sick at all many of these players
number four protest in utah over the
weekend uh over the recently passed
statewide mass mandate so utah was one
of the one of the more recent states to
join the
the mass mandate bandwagon there was a
couple of protests
unfortunately not very large protests
they should be larger than they are
i mentioned this story mainly as an
excuse to tell you about my own
mask-related run-in
um that uh that i had over the weekend
we went
um we were like i said it was at my
sister-in-law's for
for thanksgiving we went to an outdoor
christmas lights display
um at night it was saturday night again
it's
outdoors christmas lights display we're
outside
a lot of a lot of nice air circulation
when you're outside
and uh most people walking around with
masks
people i wasn't wearing really worrying
about here's let me tell you what here's
my mask policy
this is my personal policy that i've
adopted i have the neck gator thing
which doesn't do anything
but probably the cloth masks don't do
anything either but i have it
and if i'm going inside somewhere like
inside a business
i will put it on if they ask me i'm not
going to cause a scene
especially because it's some poor kid
some minimum wage you know kid
at walmart or something has to come up
and say sir will you put the mask on
i'm not going to make his job harder
than it has to be but i'm also not going
to volunteer to wear it so i'm going to
walk in without the mask if someone
tells me to wear it
i'll put it on fine outside
i will not wear it i refuse i don't care
what the what the mandate is
i don't care who says it i'm not gonna
wear a mask outside because that is
absurd
so we're walking around outside um
i'm not wearing the mask most people in
my group aren't wearing one
and this woman you know uh gets snippy
with us
and and says uh and you know confronts
us and says well i think i think masks
are mandatory are supposed to wear them
now the thing is she's holding in her
hand she's got a mask on
she's holding in her hand as am i a cup
of
hot uh spiked cider which which was very
good with whiskey in it
and so i asked her i said are are you
drinking with the mask on and that was
kind of enough to make her back away
because of course
she's not so she's walking around she'll
pull the mask
down take some sips put it back up
it's absurd it's a charade
uh the whole thing is an absolute
charade especially outside what are the
chances
okay this is this is the question i've
been asking all along haven't gotten an
answer to it
what are the chances if you're outside
and you just walk by someone
more than six feet even if you're within
six feet let's say you walk by someone
you and
god forbid you pass them uh as close as
three feet
and you're you're within three feet of
them for about a second
what are the chances that you could pass
covet to them
what is it i mean do you take the
average person just walking down the
street without a mask
yeah we don't know if he has coveted or
not just you know take any average
person off the street
walking down the street what are the
chances that that person
percentage-wise will pass coven to you
as you pass it
i mean what is what is it it's it's it's
certainly not one percentage much
smaller than that
very very very very small percentage
chance
uh but of course we know wearing the
mask is mostly as i said a
a charade something that's done you know
just for
display like with this woman it was
pulling the mask down frequently to
drink but still felt that she was
because she had it she had it on at
least she was playing the game so that
it titled her
to lecture other people uh five finally
you could be the judge here tell me what
you think
story from the hill it says a man in
arkansas
received a racist note after putting up
an inflatable black
santa in front of his house chris
kennedy who lives in north little rock
received an anonymous racist letter
condemning the decoration
kennedy read the letter during a live
stream on facebook i looked for the for
this live stream so i could play it for
you
i couldn't find it it looks like it's
been taken down which if it
it unless i just couldn't find it but if
it has been taken down maybe that'll
tell you something
here's the here's the note as he read it
please remove your negro santa claus
yard decoration
you should not try to deceive children
into believing that i am a negro
i am a caucasian white man to you and
have been for the past 600 years
your being jealous of my race is no
excuse for your dishonesty
the note continues besides that you're
making yourself the lack
laughing stock of the neighborhood
uh during the live stream kennedy said
that he was trying to be as nice as he
can be but he was filled with rage over
the note um kennedy also showed an image
of a white santa with two thumbs up
and a label taped to the envelope that
the letter came in
and then the um the property owners
association condemned it and it says
that um
other neighbors have come out and
they're buying their own black santa
inflatables to put in their yard and
they're all rallying behind this guy
okay
it's just all i can say is it's good to
see jesse smellette getting into the
christmas spirit
uh in his own way so i won't judge him
for that
and maybe that's not fair look i don't
know that this is a hoax
i i can't say that it's possible
that an actual racist person got mad
about an inflatable
santa and wrote this note where he
pretends to be
santa the the note is written as if
santa claus himself
has written it um and then i mean it's
possible right
it's you know technically it's possible
that santa claus actually did write it
it's possible look santa claus you know
he's um he's an old-fashioned guy he's
been around for centuries
so his his racial
views are probably not as enlightened as
people these days
so it's possible that an actual that
santa himself wrote it
um and then there's a cartoon
you know it's possible that a racist
person be it santa or not
was mad about an inflatable santa and
wrote the note and actually took the
time to draw a nice cartoon
of santa with thumbs down and put that
on the note all of that is possible
okay it's not impossible but history and
common sense would tell us that it's
quite a bit
more possible that this is yet again a
made-up
fake racist note from somebody begging
for attention
um all i'll say is this is that every
anonymous racist note story in recent
memory
i mean let me know if you can think of
one because everyone that comes to mind
all fake literally all of them fake
when was the last time there was an
anonymous racist note left for someone
on their porch or on their car or
whatever
written on a receipt at a restaurant
that wasn't fake
so is this the exception could be
probably isn't yet it doesn't matter
because if you look at the headlines of
this
um just like the headline i just read to
you um
almost all the headlines just report as
fact
man receives racist note not even
man says he received raises note or man
allegedly receives raises
just he received it they reported this
fact and then
you know when if and when the time comes
two or three days from now
when the police come out sort of quietly
but announce that yeah you know
this didn't really happen um then the
media they're not going to print a
correction or anything like that they're
just going to
move on as if it never happened that of
course is the way
it always goes before we get to our
daily cancellation if you missed out
on our amazing black friday deal um
let's uh i don't know first of all i
don't know what you were doing with your
time or your life you had all of friday
you fool but here's the good thing uh
today only and it doesn't it doesn't
tell me the copy to call you a fool just
to be clear i did that on my own
you could join us at daily as a daily
wire member for 50
off with code dw50 over at dailywire.com
subscribe that is today only don't miss
another opportunity
since last year's deal we've added so
many more features and products to our
membership program
we've added more exclusive readers past
content our insider and above members
can now stream content on apple tv or
roku
we've got you know you've got five hours
or rather five
five hours would be a lot five days of
the ben shapiro show
um three hours a day and also uh michael
knowles shows going uh five days a week
starting on december fourth
and if you're an all access member you
can also take part in our all access
live
which is something we didn't have last
year and that's when our hosts
uh interact with you the listener and
the viewer and we just have a sort of
casual conversation it's a lot of fun so
you get all of that and much more
we may not be able to offer this deal
again next year because of
all the stuff we're adding to it might
just not make makes sense for us to do
it so be sure to become a member today
using coupon code dw50 over at
dailywire.com
subscribe all right let's get to our
daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we're
going to cancel vanderbilt
university along with everyone in media
who is
celebrating vanderbilt university this
weekend after its winless football team
quote made history by dressing and
fielding a female player
sarah fuller a goalkeeper or as a
goaltender i'm not sure i typically
prefer sports over soccer
in any case a female soccer player was
enlisted as the vanderbilt football
team's kicker for its game on saturday
against missouri
all of vanderbilt's kickers were sent to
the coveted quarantine and the team
decided to bring sarah in
to substitute and more importantly to
generate some headlines and attention
because they certainly weren't going to
generate any headlines and attention
just by playing solid football and
winning games so they had to resort to
this
sarah thus became the first woman to
ever take the field for a major college
football program
and after the game the media went
hysterical with its adulation for sarah
fuller and her glass
ceiling breaking performance a
performance that included five for five
on field goals three of them over 40
yards
three touchbacks one game-saving tackle
just kidding of course she she kicked
once the kick went 30 yards vanderbilt
vanderbilt lost 41-0
and the coach was fired after the game
that's that's what happens in reality
now i wasn't kidding though about the
hysterical adulation part though um
that did happen including from the
announcers in the game who had the
unenviable task of having to not laugh
at the terrible kick
and instead pretend that it was some
kind of great moment for college
football
listen
[Applause]
and the kick down at the 35-yard line
and sarah fuller
happy thanksgiving what a day
what a day in college football what a
day
what a day with that 30-yard kick now i
should know that the coach
claimed after the game right before he
was fired that the kick there was a
design
squib kick and he should be fired if
that really was designed anyone who
knows football knows
you don't squibb it intentionally at the
start of the second half
when you're down 21. and even if you do
squibb it intentionally you don't want
the ball to only go
20 yards in the air and then roll
another 10. there is no
designed kick in all of football that
works like that
if this is a design kick it's a new
design it's a bad design
not a squib kick maybe we can call it a
chick kick
or we could have called it that and
laughed before our whole society turned
into a bunch of insufferable pc skulls
who would pretend that it's not
incredibly hilarious that everybody
hyped up the female football
football player then she went out and
did the worst kick anyone's seen all
year
i mean that is funny right anyway espn
of course
um interviewed sarah fuller about this
historic moment after the game and
here's what she
had to say you made history today
the first female to ever play in a power
five
football game what emotions are you
feeling now that you've reached such a
milestone
honestly it's just so exciting and the
fact that i can represent
like the little girls out there who
wanted to do this or you know
thought about playing football or any
sport really and it encourages them to
be able to step up and do something big
like this
we were all patiently awaiting the
entire first half hoping we'd get to see
you take the field but you come out
after halftime
you take the field for the kickoff what
was your mentality in that moment
honestly i was just really calm the sec
championship was more stressful
if i'm going to be honest but i was i
was really excited to step out on the
field and do my thing so
throughout this week as the story has
gained prominence and taken to the
headlines i know you felt a sense of
responsibility
to use this platform for something
bigger than yourself
what message do you hope was conveyed by
your involvement today
i mean i just want to tell like all the
girls out there that you can do
anything you set your mind to like you
really can yes do anything except
kick a football more than 30 yards
apparently it's just a good thing that
the glass ceiling was closer than 30
yards away otherwise she never would
have broken it
i am being a little harsh admittedly i
don't mean to be hard on sarah
that's why i'm not canceling her i'm
canceling everyone else associated with
this and everyone who pretended that a
bad kick by a losing team
was somehow inspirational in history
making because the person who made the
kick had xx chromosomes
though i must say that sarah almost got
herself canceled
as well when i read an espn article
about the game here's a tidbit from this
espn article it says
quote with vanderbilt trailing 21-0 at
halftime fuller decided that she wanted
to address the team
oh no if i'm going to be honest she said
quote
i was a little pissed off at how quiet
everybody was on the sideline
we made a first down and i was the only
one cheering and i was like
what the heck what's going on and i
tried to get them pumped up
she said she compared it to vanderbilt
soccer's sec tournament winning running
run when the team was quote cheering the
entire time
i just went in there and i said exactly
what i was thinking i was like
we need to be cheering each other on
this is how you win games this is how
you get better is by calling each other
out for stuff
and i'm going to call you guys out we
need to be supporting one another
we need to be lifting each other up
that's what a team's about fuller said
i think this team has struggled and
that's been part of it we really just
need to build a team camaraderie where
they can all lean on one another
it was an adjustment going from that
team mentality where hey we're all here
supporting one another
and i just wanted to bring that to this
team
okay on second thought as i read this
yes she is canceled too
extremely cancelled in fact she is very
very cancelled
you're a girl invited to kick the ball
one time as a publicity stunt
and you shank it and yet you think
you're entitled to give a pep talk to
the team
and lecture them about how how to be
better football players my lord
that's like when i when i let my
five-year-old daughter sit on my lap and
park the car you know quote unquote by
driving it 10 feet up the driveway
and the next time she was in the car
with me she started shouting driving
tips from her booster seat in the back
daddy make sure to stop when the light
is red yes i know julia thank you
thank you thank you for the tip but see
at least that was kind of cute
i have to imagine these guys were not as
amused when the girl from the women's
soccer team was strutting down the
sideline barking orders at them
although given their record and their
you know general
abilities on the field i can't say they
didn't deserve the humiliation
in fact vanderbilt sent out a tweet
after the bad kick with a picture of
sarah fuller and the words quote history
made
and the tweet reads sarah fuller
remember the name
hashtag play like a girl
yes this is a football team adopting
play like a girl as a positive motto
and credit where it's due they put their
money where their mouth is they walked
the walk
they really did play like girls and lost
by 41 points because of it
see that's what that's what happens when
you're a football team
and you play like girls or let girls
play you lose
the reason you lose is that girls can't
play football against men
i don't mean can't as in they aren't
allowed
they shouldn't be allowed but they are
allowed i mean can't as in
physically can't contra sarah fuller's
post-game interview
girls cannot do whatever they set their
minds to
they can't hate to tell you neither can
men
there are some things you set your mind
to that you can't actually do because
you're not physically capable
i could set my mind and have said it on
being the greatest
ballerina on planet earth and it
probably still will never happen
unfortunately the results ultimately
will be almost as hilarious as a woman
playing football
speaking of which there will never ever
ever ever
ever ever ever be a female who actually
earns her way onto a major college
football program even as a kicker
or even a high school program much less
a professional program
not because football teams are sexist or
because women are inferior as human
beings or anything like that
it's just because reality is what it is
a woman on a men's football team will at
best embarrass herself at worst get
herself killed
it's it's good for sarah fuller that she
didn't kick the ball 50 or 60 yards
and give the team a chance to return it
if she had and she was the last line of
defense trying to make a tackle on a
real football player with a head of
steam
sprinting down the sideline she'd be in
the hospital right now
or the morgue as far as i know no player
for a major college football program
has ever been killed by a collision on
the football field and that is
one glass ceiling a female player could
break
it's just not one that should be broken
but aside from the safety concerns the
real issue with putting a girl on the
field and celebrating her for her
terrible play
is that along with how generally
ridiculous it is
it's also patronizing and degrading
are women really so unimpressive and
bereft of achievement that we have to
pretend it's an achievement
to be given an opportunity you didn't
earn and then botch it
you know it'd be one thing if she went
in there and did hit a 52 year old
52 yard field goal for the win or even
if she managed a couple of touchbacks
but what she did literally anyone could
do
you i don't care who you are you could
kick a football 20 yards in the air if
you put it on a t
you could do that i could i think my
seven-year-old son probably could
are women so pathetic that we have to
call this an achievement
not just an achievement but a historic
achievement
one that will cause us to remember her
name for all of history
a thousand years from now they'll be
singing songs and telling stories about
sarah fuller kicking the ball 20 yards
monuments will be built is that how sad
and unimpressive women are
do we have to stoop to this answer
no that's how sad and unimpressive
feminists
think women are because they themselves
feminists
are sad and unimpressive it's how sad
and unimpressive the media thinks women
are apparently
but it's not what i think and it's not
the truth my wife for example
um can't play football
but she does 50 things in a day that are
far
more important and impressive than that
crappy kick by sarah fuller
i mean she'll do stuff like take four
young kids
by herself to a museum she's done that
multiple times
she takes all the kids i'm working
she'll go to the museum
in the city i would never do that i
wouldn't even attempt
it it's a suicide mission my wife does
it and has fun
somehow yet we don't celebrate women for
doing those sorts of things anymore
we celebrate them for for trying to
imitate men
even though their imitations always suck
and are humiliating to all involved
we've decided that the best sort of
woman is a man
and not coincidentally we've also
decided the best sort of man is a woman
so women are celebrated for dressing up
in football uniforms and
men are celebrated for dressing up in
dresses and the only people who aren't
celebrated are those who act like
themselves
and carry on living as sane and
competent people
so that's why vanderbilt is canceled and
everybody who pretended to be impressed
by the most
unimpressive kick in football history is
also
canceled and sarah fuller again
unfortunately
has to be canceled and that's going to
do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton